welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and miles morales is looking
increasingly likely to join the
live-action marvel cinematic universe or
the sony pictures universe of the marvel
characters
or whatever the weird webby sticky
blocks of new york that separate the two
are
with confirmed reports about doctor
strange joining spider-man 3 in an
increasingly likely spider-verse
crossover that will include at least
jamie foxx electro and jk simmons j
jonah jameson and all the theory webs
i've been spinning and whipping
that this is all part of a multi-title
multiverse event that
shatters the universe in one division
and condenses it all back together in
multiverse madness
in a specific way that gives us
wolverine and deadpool but how does
miles morales fit in all this
because there are rumors swirling that
spider-man 3
is gonna have three spider-men already
and if miles morales can headline in his
own awesome looking game and yeah a
wildly successful animated film he can
and i believe
he will star in his own live-action film
in the pipeline
so i'm gonna break down how this is all
gonna happen and clear up some confusion
that might be out there okay so miles
morales has already been established in
the live-action universe by aaron davis
played by donald glover
in spider-man homecoming i don't want
those weapons in this neighborhood i got
a nephew who live here
yeah sorry miles i'm not going to make
it yeah i'm just stuck
with sony seen a ton of success with the
miles morales character from into the
spider-verse the upcoming into the
spider-verse 2 and probably the miles
morales game it's a no-brainer that
they're going to be pursuing ways to
feature miles as
a human face in the mcu now last week we
heard some
unconfirmed rumors that the studio might
already have an actor locked down to
play miles morales it's not verified yet
but really none of us should be that
surprised if it ends up being true
many of us have been fan casting
stranger things caleb mclaughlin in the
role he'd be great but he is one of many
good options that are out there and it's
worth noting that this
live action mcu version of peter
parker's origin has never been
shown we do know there was an uncle ben
parker from peter's luggage and
spider-man far from home
and peter and ned talked about the
spider bite in homecoming you got bit by
a spider
can you bite me well it probably would
have hurt right
you know whatever even if it did hurt i
would let it bite me maybe
how much did it spider's dead ned i hope
that spider was the 26th one in that
experiment series
spider z or spider zed really just so
that we can get the line
zed's dead ned just saying that because
we know how the mcu loves his pulp
fiction references with nick fury's
headstone and winter soldier and happy
hogan's vince vega look in iron man 3
but seriously if we ever
do see that flashback event that same
experiment could have led to another
spider spider oh say number 42
biting another kid a young miles morales
of brooklyn nephew to aaron davis but to
be clear i think spider-man 3 is too
early to go
this deep into the existence and origin
of miles morales a quick cameo maybe but
he deserves his
own story i'm gonna break down what's
confirmed and what's not yet for this
live-action spider-verse event but uh
before i continue thank you to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
yay every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has
zero calories yet it tastes so good with
over 20 different flavors to choose from
one of those great flavors is
purple guava pear a flavor so good it'll
make you taste the purple it'll make you
see the color pair and it'll make you a
lot of some guava
all while giving you a ton of energy
check out bang on instagram you can get
25
off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea or keto coffee
flavors
you can also get clothing fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get
25 off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25 okay so what do we know
for sure about this live-action
spider-verse event well let's look at
the timeline we've been dreaming of this
kind of crossover for
years but on october 1st a couple weeks
ago the legit source of the hollywood
reporter shocked us with the
confirmation that jamie foxx elektra
would be returning from the 2014 amazing
spider-man 2 in
the upcoming spider-man 3 currently
shooting in new york and scheduled to
release december 2021. now further
rumors has speculated that fox might not
be the blue skinned electro from the
andrew garfield film but a new electro
with a more comic accurate green and
yellow costume that also yet has not
been confirmed but then a week after
that
on october 8th this time the hollywood
reporter confirmed that dr
strange would be joining this film as
well suggesting it would indeed tie into
the mcu's apparent plans for a
multiverse event this news actually
broke right as
our pre-taped episode of rogue theory
came out in which our panel was pitching
theories about the rumored returns of
toby maguire andrew garfield which yeah
now do look at least
logically more plausible but then a
couple days after that
with the growing hype of this idea some
scoopers have tried to weirdly take
ownership of this narrative
claiming that their own inside sources
that maguire and garfield were for sure
signed and confirmed
i know it for sure i can't tell you how
i know it but i do look folks
that very well could end up happening
it's just not real
yet and these folks are just betting
that it will a smart bet and the reason
they're doing it is so that they can
claim victory just to boost their
credibility when they never actually did
anything and it is impossible to prove
otherwise
meanwhile just as mysterio and john and
jameson wanted the world descends into
lies and selective reality
pro tip just don't reshare claims from
instagram accounts
please get it from legit trade
publications or the
verified social media accounts of cast
and crew but here are the facts that we
do know about miles morales in these
movies
first off as we said miles does already
exist in the live-action canon via the
aaron davis mention and based on aaron's
concern about super powered weapons in
this neighborhood i think we can assume
that miles was still a kid during
spider-man homecoming but if miles did
not get blipped
that could age him up to the same age as
peter parker
in the present day mcu you know like
that jerk brad we also know that this
spider-man 3
which i suggested last week could have a
title like spider-man home world with
home worlds this week now going around
as a rumor title that's pretty cool this
movie is already getting
real crowded with the characters we know
to be in it let alone the characters
rumored to be in it while i still think
we could see
cameos from an alternate reality within
a cross-strand of the web of life and
destiny in which miles morales is the
primary spider-man of that universe
not just a kid in nearby brooklyn but
someone who in that alternate timeline
is already the black and red suited
spider-man
i don't think spider-man 3 will be miles
morales story
yet maybe just a glimpse to let us know
like that aaron davis line that this kid
exists
and he is coming now with doctor strange
in spider-man 3 and then past spider-man
director sam rainey directing doctor
strange and the multiverse madness i
think spider-man 3 will set up the rules
of the world
in this crossover event that multiverse
of madness will execute in the end game
the way avengers end game operated
within the rules that infinity war set
up so
i think we will see doctor strange
confront the villain wanda maximoff in
multiverse of madness by the way we
ditched get confirmation that zochi
gomes is joining that cast presumably as
the star kicking multiverse hopper
america chavez that i have explored
recently but then the multiverse of
madness battle peaking
with wanda collapsing and converging the
shattered reality into
one shared universe now i doubt that we
would actually see miles during that
convergence event but
based on the rules established by the
spider-verse and spider-man 3
we could retroactively apply him riding
that convergence to end up
established somewhere within the mcu
already badass suited up as spider-man
and another thing we know for sure based
on the deal that sony and disney signed
last year
tom holland has at least two more
spider-man movies on his contract
spider-man 3
and another mystery mcu crossover event
i see
three options for what that event could
be each of which i have explored in
other videos
one an avengers fantastic 4 event set up
by ant-man 3's quantum realm
chronopolis kang and victor von doom
timeline medlin 2
an avengers secret invasion event set up
by captain marvel 2
and the nick fury disney plus series or
3 an avengers
secret wars battle world event may be
set up by
shang chi and while tom holland closes
out his contract as spider-man and
whatever that event is maybe coming as
soon as holiday season 2023
sony i believe will finally let miles
morales step up in his own
solo live-action film that is kind of
connected to the mcu what do you want
miles morales live
action film to look like and what next
avengers crossover event are you most
excited for
chat with me on new rockstar's official
discord server by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars subscribe to new
rockstars hit that notification bell
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
new rockstars thanks for watching and uh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
you